so what I thought it'd be quite fun to
do is try something that we've not
actually tried before and as to my
knowledge it's never been tried on earth
before what we want to try and do is
levitate a little droplet of beer drink
it though
and I'm just going to draw up some the
beer
while KY is like a it's a bit like an X
it's like a Greek symbol and it looks
like that so what it means to me I mean
if in physics it can mean a lot of
things but what it means to me it means
magnetic susceptibility the symbol Chi
is used in connection with both electric
fields and magnetic fields so we put a
little subscript with little e after it
that's the electrical susceptibility if
we put a little M underneath that's the
magnetic susceptibility when we normally
think of magnetic things we normally
think of you know things like like this
magnet like that like Percy the penguin
here this fridge magnet so areas
sticking to this piece of steel but it
turns out that actually everything is
magnetic so a greater or lesser degree
so in fact you and and they are magnetic
as well and this table is magnetic water
is magnetic and it's a slightly
different form of magnetism it's called
diamagnetism so this this type of
magnetism with Percy the penguin is
called Ferro magnetism it's much much
stronger now in diamagnets so I my
finger is diamagnetic Dyer magnets are
repelled from magnetic fields so Mercy's
magnet here is generating a magnetic
field so my finger should be repelled
from this magnet and and in fact it is
it's just that the force the repulsive
force is so weak with dire magnets that
I just can't feel it but if we get a
large enough magnet then we can start to
feel this diamagnetism and so we can go
next door and we'll see a magnet that
can do exactly that and in fact the
magnetic fields generated by that magnet
is so large that the repulsive force
between the magnet and in this case a
water droplet in this case is large
enough that it actually bounces its own
weight so we can float it we can
levitate it in the magnet and doing that
we can do essentially experiments
looking at how things behave in
weightlessness so a levitated object
behaves as if it's weightless in the
same sense that
and an astronaut going around the earth
believes he's weightless some people
toward the ceiling and her feet on the
floor in today's my life and if he kind
of random in fact he's still in a
gravitational field is still in the
gravitational field of the earth and we
can do something very similar using this
magnet a lot of things I've been doing
is actually looking at the behavior of
water inside a magnet and particularly
what happens when you spin it very
quickly it forms some rather interesting
shapes so I won't go into that in a more
much more detail but the other thing we
can do is put in living organisms like
bacteria and yeast and we can see how
they grow and develop in in weightless
conditions so these are experiments
which you would normally want to do on
the space station but we can do we can
do these experiments on the ground we
can see you know how how these organisms
react to weightless conditions on the
ground and we can keep them in the
magnet for days or in weeks at a time
yeah and you know for a bit of fun we've
you know levitated other objects like
strawberries strawberries things like
but you and me and strawberries fruit
and vegetables that kind of thing
they all contain of course a lot of
water and we've got our magnet set up so
that it will levitate water so we're
going into the magnetic levitation lab
now and it's in fact when you when you
get to this yellow and black line that
the magnetic field is a few times the
earth magnetic field around here and
rapidly increases as you get closer to
the magnet
until we get up to thousands of times
the Earth's magnetic field and so in
fact the Earth's magnetic field is about
50 micro Tesla in side that magnet we've
got 17 Tesla so you know the order about
a million times stronger so what I
thought it'd be quite fun to do is try
something that we've not actually tried
before and as to my knowledge it's never
been tried on earth before what we want
to try and do is levitate a little
droplet of beer so well let me show let
me just open the beer and that's
just show you what happens fine get them
so you can see that the beer at the bit
well a beer is fizzy and you can see
that the there are bubbles forming on
the glass so the little bubbles of
carbon dioxide and nucleating on the
surface of the glass so what we think is
the hypothesis is if we put this in the
magma so if we put the we put some beer
in the Magnum you get its levitate we
can we can levitate the beer so that it
doesn't have a container around it and
if it doesn't have a container around it
what what are the bubbles nucleate on so
the idea is that probably what we might
see is that there should be no fizzing
the boat the beer shouldn't fears I
think people have tried brewing beer on
the space station I'm not I'm not sure
but I think a few years ago there was an
experiment to try and brew beer well now
I think it's a problem for astronauts
actually because you know they it's a
problem for them to berg because the
bubbles don't go up so what I'm going to
do is then I'm going to use this pipette
and I'm just going to draw up some the
beer so you see the beer in there I
should just say that this this prepare
is sterile so I'm taking some
precautions you normally you're not
allowed to take food and drink into labs
but I've made sure this is all all
sterile and so on so and what I'm going
to do is then squeeze this bulb at the
end and just inject the beer into the
the magnetic trap the place where the
the beer wants to levitate so I can go
and do that now so there's a mirror on
top I mean I had to take the mirror way
to inject the beer into the magnet but
then I'll put this 45 degree mirror back
again so you can so you Brady can stand
at the edge of the room and video down
the down the mirror and see down the
ball
so there we go so you've got some beer
navigating for the first time ever this
Magnus and I can say the thumbs and
bubbles on the surface of the droplet of
beer but it doesn't seem to be fizzing
you can't get very close with your
camera but I've got a webcam
that's better
in the interest of science I'm now going
to drink the beer out of the magnet just
to make sure I understand that it's
still fizzy so I'm going to go and drink
the gun drinkers are the first I'm going
to drink through the beer out
it was still there